project Hail Mary is a fantastic book
and it's about to become a movie Welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
I recently had the absolute pleasure of
reading project Hail Mary a book by Andy
Weir who is the same author who wrote
The Martian which was later adapted to
become a movie now that movie was a huge
success and it's been announced at its
newest title project Hail Mary is also
going to get a movie adaptation the news
that this is going to be a movie is
absolutely huge because project Hail
Mary ranks higher than the Martian on
all of the book ranking websites and for
very good reason this book is fantastic
seriously if you have the money buy it
you will not regret it you can also
listen to it via an audiobook that's how
I chose to listen to it and it's
available via audible but what is the
book slash movie actually about well the
basic premise of the book is that
scientists have discovered that the sun
is dying the sun is literally getting
colder and in less than 50 years if
something isn't done about it we're
going to enter into an ice age in half
the population is going to die 50 years
after that all thereabouts we'll all be
dead there'll be no more humans left it
is an apocalypse event nope scientists
working on the problem discover
something known as the petroval line
which is an infrared line that they've
discovered going from the Sun to Venus
and back kind of like a bridge now a
probe is sent to Venus to basically find
out what this line is what the petroval
line is and they were collecting samples
when those samples get sent back to
Earth is discovered that there is
actually a microorganism which is
literally traveling to and from the sun
from Venus now the main character who's
known as Rylan Grace he was drafted in
to help solve the Petrova problem he is
uh basically an academic who was
basically humiliated in some sort of way
because of his theories and he chose to
go go into teaching he is now a high
school teacher he actually becomes the
leading Authority on these
microorganisms and calls them astrophage
it's later discovered that astrophages
actually infected multiple Stars within
our system all of them in fact except
one the star known as talcetti and thus
project Hail Mary is born it's an
Interstellar mission to find out why
talcetti out of all of the stars in our
system is not affected by astrophage
their mission is to goes to taosetti
find out the reason collect samples and
come back and hopefully save earth now
I'm not going to go too much into detail
about the story there I've left out some
key details on purpose because I want
you to enjoy this story and I don't
really want to spoil it for you but
honestly this book is amazing it's
gripping from the get-go and you really
do start to fall in love with the
characters if you like the Martian if
you like the book if you like the movie
then you're going to love project how
will marry because I absolutely loved
the Martian it was one of the first
audio books I ever listened to and it's
what got me into reading in that sort of
format I was hesitant about reading
another book from the same author
because I thought maybe it was just a
one hit wonder but he's actually
excelled and exceeded my expectations
the Martian was fantastic that project
Hail Mary is on a whole different level
now according to news articles this
information that is now becoming a movie
the main character Rylan Grace is going
to be played by Ryan Gosling but beyond
that we don't really know that much
there's no official release date but as
soon as we know more I'm going to be
updating you in another video but I want
to know what you think did you ever
watch The Martian did you ever read the
Martian have you read project Hail Mary
if you have are you excited about the
potential of their becoming a movie I
for one am super excited I loved the
Martian movie it wasn't as good as the
book I never thought I'd become one of
those people who after reading the book
and then watching the film would say the
book is better
I never thought I'd be one of those
people but it honestly was the Martian
book was way better than the movie but
it it's about a 10 hour long book
crammed down into an hour and a half so
they had to cut down some things now
project Hail Mary is significantly
longer than the Martian it's probably
about twice as long
whether or not the movie is going to be
slightly longer than what the Martian
was or whether they're going to cut out
major major parts of the story I don't
know
but my hope is that they get the key
points down they get the key
the key parts of the entire Mission all
of the things that happen all of the the
most prominent things that happen in the
book
I want them to be present in the movie
because there is some
but there are some parts of that book
that would just look fantastic on the
big screen obviously I was just using my
imagination my imagination is pretty
vivid I can imagine some pretty crazy
things but seeing it on the big screen
would be amazing but let me know what
you think like I said if you've read the
Martian if you've read project Hail Mary
let me know what you think about the
potential of there being a movie but
thank you so much for watching if you
are new to the YouTube channel make sure
you hit like And subscribe also whilst
you're down there consider becoming a
fully fledged side tracker hit the join
button down below I'll see you in
another video
foreign
[Music]